about two months ago on march 29th
at about 2 a.m on chicago's west side
residents reported hearing a series of
gunshots they called the police
and the police came when they got there
body cam footage showed later a 13 year
old boy called adam toledo started
running
shortly after he pulled out a gun and
started to toss it behind
a fence in that instant the pursuing
officer fired one shot and killed adam
toledo
so it was a tragedy of course but that
moment adam toledo's death raised a lot
of
important questions for example why is a
boy who's barely a teenager
out in the middle of the night on a city
street with a handgun where are his
parents
but no one in charge of the city of
chicago seemed interested in any way
in exploring that or any related
question how do you get a society like
that
nobody cared instead they decided on a
new policy
a quick fix they banned the police from
chasing people like adam toledo that'll
fix it
chicago's police department announced
the policy in a twitter post last week
quote
there will be specific prohibitions to
foot pursuits
chicago police will not pursue for an
offense less than a class a misdemeanor
so what does that mean exactly what
crimes qualify as quote less than a
class a misdemeanor
turns out a lot of crimes you can free
flee from the police
no problem at most that's disorderly
conduct a less serious class b
misdemeanor you can also steal someone's
purse right in front of a police officer
you can mug a woman as long as there's
less than 400
in that purse you cannot be pursued you
can trespass onto private property
you can bash a store window you can
commit assault
you can do a lot of things to degrade
and destroy society and there's nothing
the police can do to you
if you run away this is a huge change
and it's going to change chicago
profoundly so how did local media cover
this well they just lied about it
nbc chicago for example reported the
policy quote prohibits foot chases
stemming from minor traffic offenses
that's not true but the associated press
said exactly the same thing
quote the new policy prohibits foot
pursuits for minor traffic violations
but again that's a lie this policy has
nothing to do with minor traffic
violations
it's a whole category of crime some of
which are serious
and it protects the people who commit
them and that's why officials in the
city of chicago established a lot of
other restrictions on foot pursuits last
week
too many obstacles in the way no foot
chase allowed does the suspect have a
broken arm
you can't chase him and on it goes by
the way if police
officers violate any part of this policy
they can be
fired but if police decide not to chase
criminal suspects
no one says a word so do you think there
will ever be a
foot pursuit again no
of course not and that's the point if
there are no foot chases there is no
body camera footage and there's no
controversy just more crime
and if there's no footage from body cams
that means people who don't live in
chicago
won't know the condition of the city
which is grave they won't know that 13
year old boys are out carrying guns in
the middle of the night
so chicago's leaders haven't solved the
problem but they have succeeded
in burying the problem they're just
hoping you won't notice
there are city officials in other cities
who have been honest
about crime and what it takes to stop it
james craig is one of them
he was the longtime chief of police in
detroit he's reportedly at this point
considering a
run for governor of michigan this is his
first interview since he left the
detroit police department he joins us
tonight chief thanks so much for coming
on so
if hey thanks to a mugger takes a show
oh well we're honored as always if a
woman if a woman is mugged
and she's got less than 400 bucks in her
purse police can't chase the mugger what
do you think that will do
to chicago or any city with that policy
it's ridiculous tucker it is absolutely
re
it's absurd i've been in this business
44 years
i can't tell you how many individuals
i've chased on foot
to stop a violent crime and now they
want to micromanage
when you can chase is absurd
and and we're now moving into an area to
protect a criminal
but we never talk about tucker what
about
the victims what about the fam what
about the people that live in vulnerable
communities who happen to be mostly
persons of color it's shameful it is
shameful
and i got to tell you here in detroit
they want us to do our job
so so that was my next question what do
you think people who live in
neighborhoods
where there's a fair amount of crime or
in some cases a lot of crime
what do you think they think of this
they think it's ridiculous they want you
to do your job you know when i got
when i got appointed the chief eight
years ago
you know people were sick and tired of
crime and that the police were
demoralized
and so we went in and very effectively
and assertively took back our streets
we called throwing parties that's what
people
want long as you do it constitutionally
treat people with dignity and respect
and we do that right but this madness
you know what i got to tell you chuck i
was in chicago three weeks ago
met up with a couple of police officers
said chief we wish you would be
our chief i said well that's nice but
your mayor will probably fire me within
five minutes
she she's not going to want to embrace
the type of policing i believe in
and i'm talking about constitutional
policing
that makes members of our communities
feel safe this is ridiculous
talk and where we head it we're in
trouble
and the folks that talk about well you
know
we don't want police to come in
communities and
and make arrests we want to let violent
offenders out of
jail the judges as it stands right now
in detroit
we're locking up violent felonies
felons who are armed with weapons
and they laugh at our police officers
they say well i'll be out before you get
off your shift
that's why we're having violent crime if
you want to know why these cities are
having violent crime tucker
it's because of one thing the judges
are embracing this bail reform and
they're not using common
sense i'll say it and i've continued to
say it
it's wrong they're public servants just
like i was
i'm accountable accountable to the
people what about the prosecutors
what about the victims who is talking to
the victims tucker
not one person it's sad
our profession is in a crisis
a small number of people commit an
overwhelming percentage of the crime
and if they're out on the street then
you're going to have a lot of crime that
sounds like that's what you're saying
absolutely and what i'm suggesting
is talk to the victims talk to the
families
make reasonable common sense decisions
on who should be allowed out right now
i'm told
there are 13 individuals who were
charged with premeditated murder
out walking the streets of detroit
shameful
and it's not just detroit when you look
at all these cities
talk about new york talk about chicago
this is a cross so who are we supporting
the criminals
and then the aclu comes out against me
and said well well chief you got it
wrong
no you live in a gated community you're
not dealing with
what people who live in vulnerable
communities
they want the police bottom line i talk
to these folks and you know what it's
not over for me
tucker it's not over i'm going to
continue to
fight for our men and women who serve
it's not over for me
i hope you run for governor i hope you
beat your current governor badly
we'll be rooting for you james craig of
detroit great to see you thank you thank
you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else